- Why do Americans put kale in everything?
(upbeat music)
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)
- I am Jonathan Grahm
and I am the chocolatier
of Compartes Chocolates
here in Los Angeles.
Being from L.A., I came up
with the kale chocolate bar
because every single menu
in every single restaurant
was full of kale and I
was like, you know what?
How do we get more people in
L.A. to eat more chocolate?
This is the answer.
Ladle it into the mold
just like that and we're
literally gonna sprinkle and blanket
each bar with some kale.
I'm gonna add some pumpkin seeds and then
my last final bit, I'm
gonna take some of these
beautiful sesame seeds and just
sprinkle them on like that.
There we are.
(slide whooshes)
(upbeat violin music)
- Vegan chocolate?
Is that even a thing?
There's obviously some
milk in chocolate, right?
That's how I like to eat my chocolate.
- I'm vegan so I haven't had
chocolate in like over a year.
- Ohh.
- Kale and seeds?
Alright.
- Kale, I hate kale.
- A forest grew on top of my chocolate.
- Get your salad outta my chocolate bar.
- I don't know, this
doesn't look very good.
(upbeat music)
- Gosh, I forgot this flavor.
It's been so long (laughs).
- I wasn't so sure about the kale because
it just ruins everything,
but in this chocolate,
it actually tastes pretty good.
- The seeds kind of come through.
It's quite nice actually.
- Not a fan of it.
If I'm gonna get chocolate,
I want it to be sweet.
- I'm not mad.
- I like kale in my chocolate (laughs),
maybe that's just me.
- No animals were harmed
in the making of this,
which is a plus.
- So immediately I see
like this huge chunk
of kale on this chocolate.
I'm like, what is this about?
But then again, I see
there's pumpkin seeds
and I'm like mmmm, love
myself some pumpkin.